[Music]  in one word how would you tease your  finale Nick Viall talked to his big  bachelor finale ET spoke with him at the  show's women tell all peeping are you in  love are you engaged is there anything  that you would feel uncomfortable  compromising on is moving for you  something that you don't see yourself  doing I've never imagined living in  Canada and I'll be honest like that's  not easy for me to picture would the  Nesta moves to California that was kind  of a bit of an issue that we saw in one  of the episodes there and you'll have to  tune in the fonda you got very emotional  on the season you tried quite a lot what  moment sorry likes it what moment was  parted for you to watch sunny rich  aromas world yeah my relation with  rachel is very strong  Oh card